excuse me drink the milk of the puppy
it's got nose is poison cyanide in your
goblets
[Music]
so you know how LA's going through this
ongoing thing of uh I guess California
as a whole how people leave because
they're mad about this social crime
policy although that's just happening in
all the blue cities like it's happening
in Hawaii it's happening like all kinds
of places that's very very blue I love
the criminals yeah so this example is a
little bit different in another
Direction because what what a lot of
people say is like oh man you gotta let
them out they're gonna do another crime
and then let him out again another crime
and then they always go back to the
first time you're arrested and go why
wasn't he still in jail because of this
yeah you know but in this situation it's
got a little bit of a difference and
it's interesting so back in August 2021
there was a viral video you guys may
have seen it we didn't cover it here I
don't think
um but it was where this lady was
pushing a baby on a stroller going down
Venice uh in the city of Venice you know
those like little Alleyways Yeah Yeah by
the beach just pushing her baby on a
stroller a car is driving through the
alleyway and then turns to I saw this
yeah it like turns to aim at her and
then runs both of them like whoa both of
them into the air stroller and the mom
see the it's like a movie where she
flies the stroller fly the baby flies
the mom's a chi though after she got hit
she got it back up immediately and went
to this went straight to the baby baby
was fine thank God oh my God that baby
seat belts or something that's a good ad
for the [__] stroller dude no so
luckily no injuries for the baby I think
she was she was banged up what they
found out later that uh the person that
hit them was a 15 year old kid who had
stolen that car and was already uh he
was already on on probation for a bunch
of [__] right yeah for some [__] and
then and then so rather than go to jail
the D.A like recommended uh seven months
probation camp because he's a juvenile
yeah this is a little bit different from
a repetitive offending like meth head
that's like 50 years old oh no he's yeah
he it is different but it this very
early age he's already under felony
probation for poisoning some girls drink
Jesus poison I was trying to kill
somebody like a medieval politician like
damn excuse me drink the milk of the
puppy
I've crushed these grapes this morning
for you my tire a little extra treat
poisonous
stupid uninvestigatingly what's going on
so this kid's already tried to kill
three people not only that but so he
gets sentenced to that seven month
Croatian camp and uh and of course the
mom is like livid that that that's all
he's getting plus they're like oh by the
way his record will be cleaned by 18 but
she was like that was attempted murder
but that is what happens for juveniles
oh yeah so the and adults right now
so the family that uh the mother the the
kid that family moved out of LA and said
good screw this place whatever uh what
do you think ever happened to this kid
when did this happen he just killed
somebody this happened two years ago so
that's what I was thinking well you're
presenting it in a way where there's a
happy ending I'm thinking he cleaned
himself up went to college maybe maybe
became a police officer that was only
two years ago when he was 15 then right
that kid grew up in two years and
assassinated him for attacking his mom
what's up oh the baby baby
with milk of the puppy
hey
taste close next episode
a very short season yeah but a very
strong debut toddler assassin so this
happened just the other day same kid so
he's out
um he happened to get into an argument
with some random person outside of a
fast food restaurant and got shot to
death oh [__] by the baby
it was a baby in the hood but the crazy
thing is that the mother who originally
was hit by the car is like
pissed at the D.A because they're like
you could have saved his life by putting
him in jail oh because you just let him
back out if you're running the streets
it goes both ways exact cause more harm
or other harm incomes and that's what I
didn't think about I'm like that's true
because the climate of his life doesn't
change he's into a bunch of bad [__] he
doesn't go to jail it doesn't have no
rehab yeah and his everything is still
in the same exact places for him to do
bad [__] Nothing's Gonna help him so he
went right back out got into the same
exact lifestyle some [__] just happened
to him got shot to death and now like
they're mad at the day for that wow he
got shot outside of a fast food
establishment yeah was it an Arby's
wiener schnitzel they're not saying
because they probably don't want to kill
that business
I was gonna say he's probably arguing
over which one's better a chalupa or
Supreme Taco chalupa dude duh I'd have
to disagree where's my God
nobody [__] knows that the Doritos
[__] Supreme Taco is the best
when you get a Cool Ranch yeah but then
the chalupas deep fried fluffy yeah and
it's fluffy oh [__] we're gonna happen
Supremes but the deep fried fluffy
crunchiness and if you get the Steak
Chalupa oh my God
yeah they want a chalupa now dude but
they don't have the outside Ranch layer
dust on the edge that's how the gang uh
watching Gaga forms
yeah dude that's isn't that a crazy
thing that likes yeah that's the other
side that Mom is mad like because she's
like I told you to put him in jail for
what he did there's got to be one
percent of that Mom that's like
riddance she's actually not that's
it but you know what though she said
even if they even if they uh like uh
prosecute him to the full extent of the
law this is still worse and she didn't
want this uh death yeah they would have
put it to death for what he did but
she's like I just wanted him to get the
full extended she's a really good person
because if that was if I was the Mom I'd
be like good that's how I think I was
[__]
celebrate
what most people want ideally is someone
goes to jail and then they get reformed
and then they come back into society and
become a functional member that's what
everyone wants but realistically that's
not what [__] happens dude no that's
that [__] does not happen it happens if
you're streaming lucky it's such a weird
situation because I feel like when I was
younger I I just wanted people to be
punished for the full extent of the lot
right but as I've gotten older I know
some of the worst people on Earth
because they've had opportunities and
chances to become a better person
they're some of the most
best people I've ever met like I
specifically remember and I told the
story on my podcast where my friend's
older brother when I was younger you
know I was a kid that used to joke
around a lot right but when you're when
you're when you're a goofy ass like
stupid ass
and you know
you know jokes with all these people
like you don't know that some people run
with a different set of rules so I'm
like four years younger and I'm making
jokes or whatever right but his older
brother didn't find it funny that I made
him the butt of the joke and you know
you can't make fun of somebody who's
like an Affiliated gang member in front
of other people and that he's not gonna
check your ass but I'm not and again I'm
just the his younger brother's friend
he's a court gesture exactly he didn't
know he was dealing with a knight
thought that it would be okay and I
remember the shit's most traumatized
experience I was [__] 14 years old or
13. either way and he put a gun at my
[__] dick in front of everybody and I
just locked up right and I went back
home I started crying I was bawling at
my eyes this guy I met at a wedding last
year he's a pharmacist now
he's a [__] fart and this fool comes
up to me right he goes what's up David
and you know a little PTSD a little bit
about what's up guys like no please
oh he remembers of course he did he
[__] scared he probably did that to
everybody
but how many dicks did I point my gun at
yeah but that guy is a church leader now
he's a pharmacist like he does so many
great things but he was allowed time to
to change himself right so I had this
weird perception in a correctional
facility I don't know what happened I
don't know his previous sir we didn't
talk for that long because I was already
crying but
I have seen more often times than not
for people that I grew up with that
became better individuals for whatever
happened in between right so I never
want to take that opportunity for
somebody to better themselves not to say
that how you feel about these situations
like I feel against because I just don't
know but because I've seen people change
over time to become better I like the
opportunity so I understand her
sentiment of like okay this person can
change and be better because I've seen
it multiple times I could name off a
dozen people right now who've gotten
some probably even us right when you
guys talk about your past stories
because when we when we start sentencing
sentencing people you know if they're
like oh this person should die well I
guess all of us should die here then
because how many bad things have we done
personally I'm a good boy
[Laughter]
I did steal a big rubber band yeah you
go to hell bro how big was this rubber
band
wow how dare you you know how many
[__] Vietnamese kids made that
[__] rubber band for nothing for
nothing
[Music]
like crochet rubber band It's Not sewing
it is
the cool thing she said was that it it
sends the wrong message entirely when
when you just fight so hard to keep
people out of any type of likes of your
punishment because it just makes them
think oh I got away with it yeah like I
did yeah what does it teach anybody yeah
so it's not that she wanted this kid to
die or she wanted him to like rot in
prison she was like just don't give him
the idea that that there's no concept
because it usually it escalates yeah
exactly oh if I do this and nothing
happens then I'll do this what happens
oh nothing happens you just keep
escalating it's like big herk if he
didn't do 15 years he didn't for bank
robbery first year second year third
year he was in jail for 15 years yeah
yeah it's just a it's such a weird thing
to think about right because you know
Lawson specifically like Joe was saying
in blue states have become so [__]
relaxed that people feel like they could
do whatever the [__] they want because
what are the real consequences and also
makes you feel like someone could do
that to you and get it yeah and if you
you know like let's say for example
somebody comes and robs your store and
you try to put your hands on them
they're like well they could sue you
yeah but it's like
trip them on the way out yeah shouldn't
have done that see these [__] bananas
guys
I'm gonna sue you for this right here
yeah we have friends that are cops and
then they'll see people like get caught
with drugs right and uh they get let out
because it's for some reason that's part
of like the narrative that they're doing
where they're like oh this is a better
Rehabilitation form then you have like
an old white guy that gets caught with
like maybe under the table dick pills
and they get 10 years in jail yeah like
how does that work it's like well that
guy knew better and then well it's like
but what's the real crime though you
know it's crazy because like a world
without consequences is a very odd world
to live in right because there's no
checks and balances you know when we saw
those videos out in the Bay Area people
literally smashing Windows stealing
hundreds of thousands of dollars and you
see employees just I mean it's a good
thing that they have to just watch it
because right first place but they know
that nothing is going to happen at most
they'll get put into like a cell for two
days and they'll just walk the [__] on
out like it's just I don't know man
that's what hurts me to see them
watching it happen is that these people
are at work like they're trying to make
an honest living and they're watching
people make a dishonest living off of
their honest living yet they can't do
anything about it and they get to see
them come back on Thursday and then
Tuesday and then Friday and then imagine
doing the report to the cop and telling
them all [__] and just feeling like
there's no point to this one of the most
satisfying videos I've ever seen and
also well I guess I'm a little sick but
this guy put his hand into this guy's
Doorway to steal it and he had the bat
not today for the
thank you
I Was So Satisfied in my life I mean he
didn't kill him which I don't want but
he definitely he gonna learn the dirt
it's so he remembers that it's like it
is
what was he trying to steal just mail
like mail or package yeah
he's trying to open the door or some
[__] yeah credit card or something
it looked like a skit because both
parties were ready yeah so that audio
wasn't wasn't like oh [__] I thought
that was like inputted no that was his
actual scream that was his actual screen
I thought that that was the Tom and
Jerry sound so did I
watching people defend themselves
without the end being death is I enjoy
very much yeah because somewhere in
there there's a lesson at least yeah
yeah I don't like watching people die
life is very very valuable plus if a
video gets viral of that person it's
like an extra lesson like a residual
lesson it was like that viral video of
the of the bus driver who uppercut
yeah
I know it sounds really bad when I say
it but
but what do you say he's like you go
learn it no yeah you're gonna learn
today it was some phrase but he just
uppercuted the [__] out of her dude
video game dude he loaded up too for me
he was just down down Fierce yeah
somebody had to call it ambulance
go to Amber Lamps
foreign
[Music]
thank you